okay testing testing
uh
thank you members
um
good evening members officers and
members of the public uh can i welcome
you to this planning committee meeting
of the 15th of december
as always a little bit of housekeeping
which i'm sure you know by now but i
have to do this
one i will add um
i'll leave it up to yourselves
if you wish to wear
face covering this evening but if you
are speaking
please just lower it down so we can hear
you clearly
if the firearm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security door to my
right
or use the stairs opposite the lifts
please do not
use the lifts
i won't show you at the bottom of the
stairs go across to hawley square um and
stay there until an officer of course
it's safe to come back in and carry on
the meeting
uh does anybody intend filming this
meeting this evening
thank you mr alban i expected that from
you um
rich rich can of course mobile phones
with members please
uh and members of the public make sure
their phones are turned to silent and
not to use them for any purpose to take
calls or make calls while this meeting
is in progress
are there any members wishing to speak
on
20.1
i can't see any
notification
public speaking uh the foreign
application has been reserved for public
speaking but members please make a note
item 5a
801
2021 bayview
road in broad stairs
a gender item one apologies for absence
i have apologies from councillor
hopkinson who is substituted once again
by
cal sir curry
and councillor hart who is substituted
by
councillor pugh
both welcome
item 2 declarations of interest
remembers
no thank you
a minute
uh agenda item three the minute saw the
planning committee meeting that was held
on the 17th of november 2021
uh the members agree that the minutes of
the planning committee meeting held on
the 17th 21 be approved and signed by
myself could i have a proposal please
uh thank you councillor robin the second
please counselor coleman cook
um
all in favor those who are here
all agreed
thank you
moving on to a point of information am i
going to hand over to mr livingston
please
thank you chair uh just a point of
information for members on agenda item
5a which is uh 21 bayview road this
evening
on plan condition number two one of the
plans stated in the agenda is down as
zero seven a received on the third of
november which should actually be
0 7 b received on the 6th of december
which is the plan submitted and on the
public website and therefore the
condition is corrected before members
thank you chair
thank you thank you ian
so agenda item 4
is 17 northumberland avenue
uh i've been asked the planning officer
which i was in once again to outline the
report please
thank you chair
um so the application site is outlined
in red for
number 17 northumberland avenue as the
proposal is for the erection of
single-story rear extensions on both
sides with a roof extension with a gable
end to one element and a flat roof
dormer
so members visited the site
a couple of five days ago i'm just going
to go through all the plans and then and
also some photos for those that didn't
attend
so
if we move through so this is an aerial
image
of uh the area so the main neighbors
that were looked at on the site visit
were
11 lonsdale avenue which is this
property here if you can see the mouse
and then there's the property on the
corner and the property the the other
side of the current bungalow
so
this is number 17 in the middle here
you've got the two neighbors either side
and then
looking from the rear and this is the
existing rear of the property
so looking then on the right hand side
of the rear um so this projection that's
currently in place is is quite important
because that's where the proposed rear
extension would be coming out to that
line but filling in the square to the
left where the current conservatory is
and then looking down the side so to the
right of this photo
is down that side access so this is the
area adjacent to the neighbor that's
that's effectively going to be filled in
by a rectangular single story extension
which is a flat roof
a flat roof design
and then this is turning to the right of
that image to look at the neighboring
property with the the dorm window on the
side there
and then the other side
which shows you can just see behind the
the trees here you can see the roof of a
sort of single story accretion at the
back of the property which is on the
corner which is the the two-story
property
so um members walked into the rear
garden and then we went to number 19
first and stood in that garden then went
to number 11 lonsdale in that garden and
then went round to number 15.
so just going through the plans then you
can see those two sections which are
going to be filled in at ground floor
so at the front um you've got this
existing
elevation which would then be changed so
that
you effectively come off the existing
ridge height of the property extending
to the side with a roof that pitches
away from the frontage with that uh that
side gable
in this area here
then looking at the side elevation so
this is the side elevation that faces
towards the neighbor with the dormer
window so um this roof here will we'll
see from a different angle from the rear
elevation at single story level here
this is actually a flat roof element
and then this is the other side
elevation facing towards the two-story
property
again you can see at the moment the
projection of that rear element with the
conservatory and then the roof slope
which we're going to look at a bit more
detail
here
and this is the proposal so you can see
that you've got a new gable end creating
a first floor uh at the rear extent of
the building at the moment and then you
have a dormer window which is
accommodated in a new roof slope which
which sort of has the ridge height going
up to the existing ridge higher the
property which is higher than the ridge
of this section at the moment
so then the rear elevation um one thing
i mentioned to members on the site visit
was that i was going to outline a little
bit about the question about permitted
development because obviously that's one
of the points that's raised in the
agenda about what can be done without
needing planning permission at the
moment
so within the rear roof slope what could
be accommodated there broadly would
involve being able to put a dorm window
in the central section of
this
this roof slope here as annotated by the
mouse
because you have
different ridge heights on the
properties you can see from this
elevation
a roof extension could go up to as long
as it's below the highest point of the
whole roof so you can see at the top
where the ridge part ridge
terminates here
um you could actually have an extra
extension that goes above the roof line
of the main body of the roof but as long
as it doesn't go higher than the main
pitch
then
you know that that could be permitted it
does depend on a few other caveats so
materials have to match in appearance uh
it does have to you know it doesn't it
does have a volume limit but what you
could accommodate is a dorm window with
first floor windows facing to the rear
in this uh in this rear roof slope now
one of the important points that i do
want to point out to members
is when looking at the side elevation
because i think this is the easiest way
to see what the impact is
you can see the existing side elevation
here of the property so the rear is on
the right hand side of the image
the rear elevation
and this this main
so this this ridge section roof section
here is the section which they could
extend
now what that would mean because they
there's they would need to extend to the
rear
to basically push past the existing rear
elevation of this section that's here
what that means is that any door window
erected under permitted development
would not be as close to the rear
boundary as what's being proposed here
but the difference involved
is about a meter and a half
so you're only looking at a meter and a
half additional
in terms of that
that depth that this this extension is
proposing from what you could erect
under permitted development and we'll
look at what distance what the
difference that makes in distance when
we look at the block plan in a second
so just to show you then the rear
elevation what's actually been proposed
in this
this application
so what's happening is the overall ridge
is increasing over the um the existing
ridge but only in that gable end the
main body of the roof is not going
higher than the existing roof height of
the of the property but what you are
getting is these first floor windows
within the dormer and within this new
gable feature so the area that members
were directed to look at in particular
uh were were the windows that were on
the left-hand side of the image at first
floor level um and we'll show
this if i click through uh sorry if i
click through to the block plan in a
second
um so it's the relationship with the
neighbour at the rear
in terms of overlooking that's
particularly important in terms of what
the actual
proposal is doing inside you've got an
existing ground floor plan there
showing it as a three bedroom property
what's occurring then is that there is a
extensions at the ground floor level
and then at first floor what you're
doing is you're creating a bedroom so on
the right hand side of this image you
can see the windows that face to the
rear so you've got a bedroom window
within that gable
that's created and then you have an
ensuite window in the middle
and then on the left hand side if you
were to look at it from the rear you've
got another bedroom window
and then this is the existing
roof plan of the property so the front
elevation is on the left hand side and
the rear elevation is on the rear
and that shows then the the flat roof
dormer that's being put in there
so just to clarify with regards to the
the relationship with the neighboring
properties um
it's considered by officers that in
terms of the impact on the neighbors
either side number 15 and number 19
because of the relationship with where
habitable room windows are and where the
bulk of the property in terms of the
extensions are that it's not considered
to cause an impact on the main habitable
rooms or cause a loss of privacy from
the way that the windows so the
direction that the windows are facing in
the extension
in terms of the relationship with the
neighbor to the rear
um it's acknowledged in the report that
there is an impact that would be caused
by this proposal
but the weight to be given to the
fallback that's available by being able
to erect a dorm window in the rear roof
slope um means that this this proposal
is considered to be acceptable on that
basis in terms of the difference in in
distances um that we're talking about to
the to the neighbors at the rear um
effectively from the um
from the existing
the existing property um you have about
10.5 meters to the rear boundary
that joins number 11.
with the new dormer window
the the dormer window would be about 12
meters from that boundary
if it was built under permitted
development it would be about
13.5 meters from that boundary and on
that basis it's not considered that
meter and a half would change the fact
that the relationship of overlooking
would be created by what would be
permitted development
and therefore taking into account that
as also the impact on the character
appearance the area obviously members
could see when on site that there's
two-story property next door there are
roof extensions on a number of
properties it's not a fixed character it
is considered that the proposal is
acceptable and therefore it's
recommended for approval
thank you chair
uh thank you ian um i move the officer's
recommendation
be adopted because vice chair please
second oh second thank you
thank you council common cook members
accounts for organ
yeah thank you chair um
i like most of us attended the uh
site visit and
first of all i'd like to thank the
residents uh the adjoining
properties for letting us come in
muddy their back gardens
etc with our footprints and um thank
them for that because it was important
i think but what's lost
what's lost to here but just looking at
the drawings and the site layout and
everything
is the amount of vegetation that's
around
that's within the adjoining gardens and
the gardens of number 17.
um
perspective
looking at what's
proposed
is acceptable
the design is acceptable i think it fits
in
as it stands the property uh number 17
is basically
dwarfed by either either side the
buildings either side um
and whilst i was
a bit concerned uh about over
overlooking at number at number 11. i
take the view
of miss of mr livingston and
on the whole chair i think it's uh
i think i'll i will go
for approval thank you chair uh thank
you council auburn councillor keane
thank you chair um yeah given what could
be done under permitted development
anyway
um and having been on the site visit and
seen the neighbouring properties then
i'm quite happy that this fits in with
the neighborhood scene and i will be
supporting it
uh thank you councillor keane uh
councillor joel bayford
thank you chet yeah i wasn't able to
attend the last meeting but i did attend
site visit
and i think i agree with everything that
council auburn and uh
you know i i think that you
you've summed it up really it is dwarfed
by the other buildings anyway
um so much can be done under competitive
development anyway i feel that the small
difference
uh
really doesn't cause any more harm so i
i will support this application yeah
thank you councilman for council
rusevski
i'm with the other councillors also
agree that uh
um the actual application
um would be should be approved i can't
see any problems there because permitted
development give them almost that in any
case so thank you chair
uh thank you council pew
thank you chair um it was just a
question for ian really am i right in
thinking that
uh under permitted development there
would be an increase in the overall
floor floor space more than this
application or is it light for light the
exact same
um in terms of floor space this is more
than what would be allowed under
permitted development because you've got
the ground floor extensions as well
and there's a gable end that would be on
the i suppose on the south of the the
properties you look at it on on this
that's that's created um so the floor
space itself that was created would be
created i'm sorry i do apologize i said
that wrong i'm in uh the overall ground
space particularly on the ground floor
not up in the first round will that be
the same as under permitted development
is it going out as far or is it going
out more or less that's that's what i
was trying to ascertain apologies for
not being clear
um thank you i'm just looking i'm just
looking at it um it looks like from if
we just took it as as
a um what would be a
i think the side extension as you look
at it um
from which is the top of the the site as
you look at it um i don't think that
would be covered under permitted
development because it's a rear
extension to the existing property
effectively even though it looks like a
side it's actually going off a rear wall
as well
but the bit in the corner as you look at
it on the bottom of the image would
likely be covered under permitted
development
thank you
are you happier that uh council viewers
i am thank you chair thank you thank you
uh
any other members who wish to speak
and i would like to say on a very damp
morning thank you for those members who
did turn up at the site
visit and i certainly understand some
can't because of other commitments um
right i'm going to put this to the vote
with yourselves um those in favor could
they show please
any against
absentians
that is carried thank you very much
members thank you
moving on now to agenda item five which
is the schedule of planning applications
and public speaking
any site visits that do take place or if
they're agreed tonight will take place
on friday the 7th of january 2022.
agenda item 5a is the planning and
application for approval of 21 bay view
road in brussels
and speaking in favor and i have got
this the right way around is
for the application is mr
peters
thank you mr peters thank you you have
three minutes
okay thank you chair thank you members
uh my name is cecil peters i've lived in
broadstairs for over 22 years and i've
always gotten really well with my
neighbours and so i'm a little sad and
disappointed that we've had an objection
to our plan
um
we were thoughtful about how we built
our extension we didn't go up the full
second floor level we've got up just
below that to be sympathetic to the area
our two properties are six meters more
than six meters apart so there's quite a
gap between us and the house to the left
of us was a bungalow and that's already
been extended upwards so we feel like
there's um
there's prior in terms of uh
this this type of development
um
we
we got feedback on our first application
that they their neighbors thought they'd
be overlooked so we've made sure that
the windows have got obscured glass now
and that was in the revised plan and
we've got a smaller window because the
windows are really for ventilation on
the first floor they're not for viewing
so we hope that you know we've covered
off those objections
um this for us is our forever home so
we're going to really take care we're
going to use the best materials we're
going to put
everything into making it a beautiful
place and a house that the road will be
proud of
um so from our perspective we hope that
uh everything that we're trying to do is
intentional and it will be beautiful and
it'll be our forever home thank you
okay thank you very much mr peters uh
speaking raising points of concern mr
thorne again you have three minutes mr
thorne thank you thank you very much um
again i've lived in senec for all my
life
57 years of them
and i've never had to complain about
something before or object to anything
but
it's actually come hard to us this was
there meant to be a forever home as well
and unfortunately it seems like our
daylight is being taken away from us and
our light
the case officer reported
it is not considered that the proposed
work will create any additional harm in
terms of light reduction and
overshadowing this i beg to differ if
you've seen the pictures that i uploaded
you can see how greatly it reduces it
and i've got photos here with me
to substantiate that as well
it can clearly be seen by my photos at
the impact that will have on the
bungalow
and it shows the overshadowing
of the property at number 19 on the
proposed property of number 21.
it was also quoted that the stun
disappears behind the dwellings from our
south side wall at 11 40.
we continue to gain the sun all
afternoon
the proposed property is overshadowed
overshadowed as photos showed by the
neighbours on their roof height
having been a regular visit to our
previous assignment to the previous
owner of the proposed property up until
august this year we know firsthand the
impact of the overshadowing has
the need of electric lighting during the
daytime hours and the loss in heated
elements from
from passive solar games was evident
our bow glow on the other hand gains all
these elements
we don't want to be forced to increase
our already utility bills
we no longer built benefit and the
proposed
height additional is accepted
coast officer also quoted difference in
height is a minor increase
i consider over two meters not a small
amount
any height would cause harm in the terms
of light reduction and overshadowing
the design does not mirror
number 19 as quoted by the clay officer
photos show
the roof length of number 19
does not run the full length of the
bungalow and only a small frosted window
is evident at the rear
number 21 proposed plans include a roof
line the full length of the bungalow
including two windows serving as
bedrooms
this will impact on the privacy of our
rear garden due to the fact that our
garden sits at a higher level than that
of our property
we have worked very hard
i'll give you a moment uh
mr thorne
we've worked very hard on our property
and it was meant to be our forever home
for our retirement in a sony bunk life
now this
now has caused us to suffer from mental
health issues and stress
i applaud you to talk
i applaud you to consider my objections
thank you
thank you mr thorne
i'm sorry you feel
i'm kidding upset i i am very upset i am
really upset if we can leave that and
then please uh
um i'll ask the planning officer to
outline the report and ask emma please
thank you chairman
um
this is the application site outlined in
red
here so it fronts on to
um bayview road and you can see duncan
park drive is on the right-hand side
here
and this area in between is
an open grassed area so you can see the
property from dunson park drive and to
the rear of the site is the railway line
this is the application property here so
this is number 21 bay view road
um and you can see on the left there's
two story dwellings
and this is again showing property to
the left so this is number
19 bayview road
and then you can see the the two
property to the left of that number 17
and 15 bayview road um
number 15 has had
alterations recently to to extend and
you can see it's quite a modern design
and then this is to the right hand side
this is looking to the neighbor um
number 23 bayview road this is the the
property
raising some concerns regarding the
impact of the light
and you can see the gap between the
existing properties and you can see the
ground level slight ground level change
between the two properties
and then again this is looking at number
23 and this is a closer view looking
towards the side elevation of number 23
so you can see there's existing windows
and a door within this side elevation
with a setback garage and again you can
see the the distance between the
properties
so the application is for
a first floor extension above the
bungalow to create a two-story dwelling
a single story rear extension
a single story extension to the front of
the garage
and at first level there's a balcony
also proposed to the front elevation
so this is the existing layout of the
existing bungalow
so you can see the garage to the bottom
of this slide
so the proposal was to extend this to
the front here
um
and then you can see this is the
proposed ground floor extension so
this area here is the proposed rear
extension so the rear extension is 2.65
meters deep
and it's set away from the boundary
and by approximately two meters
you can see um in the bottom here this
is the front projection of the garage
area so from this point here to here so
the garage projection is 1.97 meters
and then this is the proposed first
floor extension so this would achieve
four bedrooms at first full level and
you can see there's a balcony at the
front elevation looking towards the road
within the side elevation there's three
windows and that's they're looking
towards number 23.
so two of those serve bathrooms and one
of them is a secondary bedroom window
and then there's a further window
along this elevation serving the landing
so from the front this is the existing
front elevation of the property so you
can see again pitch roof bungalow
traditional design with the side side
garage
and this is the proposal
so you can see in terms of the first
floor extension the increase
to eaves level is approximately 2.2
meters
so um
in terms of first level the eave level
is slightly below
the level that you would expect if it
was a 42 storey height so it's a
slightly dropped ease level
and in terms of the ridge height
the ridge is increasing by 2.2 meters
beyond the existing ridge height of the
bungalow
you can see that the front elevation is
changing in terms of material so they're
proposing to clad to the front elevation
with timber cladding and in terms of the
glaze and you can see it's quite a
modern design and it's proposed to have
gray either upvc or aluminium windows
the balcony is located in this area here
with glazed balustrading and it's a
projecting balcony and this area here is
a boundary wall so it's not an extension
it's a wall containing a gate to the
right-hand side
this is the existing south elevation so
you can see the existing garage on the
left-hand side here and the existing
windows so it's looking at the floor
plans and looking at the layout it would
appear that this bongo is likely to have
a similar
layout to the neighbor number 23
which as you can see from those the
photos i showed you they also had two
side windows
so it's it's believed that this one
would serve um the bedroom window and
this one um a kitchen
and this is the proposed side elevation
so you can see here the front garage
projection you can see the the first
floor extension
and the the balcony projection at the
front so
the proposed garage will block out their
existing ground floor side window
and then this is the hallway window at
first full level
and you can see the the rear projection
again a single story level
then this is the elevation facing number
23. so this is the existing side
elevation facing the property
and this is the proposed side elevation
so again you can see the balcony
projections the front there's the
proposed windows at first full level so
these two central windows were the
windows serving the bathrooms and this
high level window was the secondary
window to the front bedroom um and
additional windows proposed at ground
floor level and again to the hit to the
rear this is the the single storey
extension
and then in terms of the rear extension
um rear elevation even this is the
existing
and this is then the proposed so this is
the rear renovation of the existing
garage which is being altered slightly
this is the proposed rear extension
which again you can see with large
um
glazed doors and again you can see the
clad in the first world level and on the
left-hand side here that's the boundary
wall um that's along the front of the
site so again not an extension but a
boundary wall that would provide um side
access
so in terms of the actual character
appearance as you saw from the
elevations it's quite a modern design
and again it's a created a two-story
dwelling but
as you can see in this photo properties
off to the left-hand side
this property here is similar in
appearance it's not the same but very
similar appearance it has the same
shallow roof pitch and also has um quite
extensive glazing and the balcony at
first full level
and again you can see on the left hand
side here again a very modern design so
in terms of the actual design of the
development it's not considered that the
the height or the scale or the
appearance would be out of character of
the area given the fact that these
properties off to the left hand side of
of the of the existing building
but the concern is is potentially the
impact on the neighbour so when looking
at the impact on the neighbor
i'll just go back to this block plan
here
so no part of the extension is coming
close to the boundary with the
neighboring property but the concern is
with the increase at first floor level
of the creation of the first floor
extension by the 2.2 meters and the
impact on the windows within this side
elevation here
so there is a distance of 6.5 meters
between this elevation and the existing
elevation of number 21.
um
as mentioned it's understood that it's
likely that this is a a primary bedroom
window in this location here um and if
again if it's based on the the floor
area that we have had before us for this
property then this would be a secondary
kitchen window
um if that's the case obviously in terms
of outlook there's already limited
outlook given the fact that the windows
are facing onto the existing boundary
treatment for the property so at ground
floor level
given the fact this is a bungalow
there's already
um limited outlet for these windows so
the main issue is the impact on light
now with the increase in height there
will be some impact on these windows in
terms of impact on light
this is north facing elevation so in
terms of the increase in height as the
sun comes round from the east to the
south this increase in height will have
some impact on on the light to these
windows
but we have to consider whether the
impact is significant enough to warrant
refusal
um and in this instance given the
distance
um and given the fact that these are
side facing windows
it it's not considered that the impact
will be significant enough for us to
warrant the refusal of the application
on the increased height of the building
um in terms of the rear extension it's
not considered that this would have any
um significant impact on the windows of
the neighboring property again this is a
garage here and there's still a distance
of approximately two meters from this
point here which also is similar rear
building line to the nobling garage
and whilst um first floor side windows
are proposed it adapted on the plans
that these would be obscure glazed to
serve bathrooms and the one bedroom
window would be high level so it's not
so that these windows would actually
cause
a loss of or significant loss of privacy
for the neighboring property
um i think the um the neighbor mentioned
the potential loss of privacy from the
first floor rear windows but when we
assess applications we have to look at
whether it's direct overlooking or
indirect overlooking in this case it
would be indirect overlooking because
the main view from these first four
windows would be to the rear looking
towards the railway and would not be
resulting in significant loss of privacy
for this rear garden area here due to
the angle of the windows
at the front the balcony is unlikely to
result in significant loss of privacy
either because it's mainly again looking
towards the road area or to the frontage
of this property where it's more for
parking but not not actually private
immunity space
in terms of this um garage
projection here it's very minor only 1.9
meters deep
and there's
limited windows and on this side it's
not considered that this would result in
significant harm it's flat roof so it's
not considered this extension would
cause harm to number 19. so just to show
you again this side elevation of the
neighbor
they're the existing windows this is the
the 6.5 meter gap
and then the increase of the two meters
as mentioned is not considered that this
would actually be significantly harmful
enough for us to warrant refusal on on
the impact on this window alone because
as
you can see this appears to be a
secondary window serving this room here
with their main primary window being at
the front
so overall it is considered that the
application is acceptable and is
recommended for approval thank you
thank you emma i move the officer's
recommendation is adopted because the
vice chair please second or second
nurture uh thank you council colin cook
um members uh councillor keane
thank you it's just a question um what's
at number 25 if we is that a two-story
building or what
can you go back home
no it's another bungalow okay thank you
okay thank you
uh cal scholar
thank you
thank you yeah
i do have
i have a couple of concerns um i've
listened to the officers report
and there are a number of issues that
taken in isolation
may
may not be good enough reason to
seriously consider
rejecting this proposal
the loss of light issue on its own maybe
losing like some light during a day
uh may not be on its own good reason to
to um consider refusal
um i am concerned that
that this is a basically a total
conversion from uh
from one of a number of bungalows in
that area
to the house basically and i can
understand there are other buildings the
other side that are houses
but
this isn't a this is a
an area where there is a mix of
bungalows and houses
and i think if we keep picking off
bungalows in the area and converting
them into houses
you know it's a steady sort of drip drip
um
effect that we end up with no no
bungalows
left in the area and i think it's
important
that you know that there is this mix so
i think there could be
there could be a good reason to consider
refusing this on the basis of it does
affect the character and appearance of
the area because it convert helps
convert the area from a mixed
development
to
totally
um houses
so i mean i'd like i obviously want to
hear what other people might have to say
but um
i will need to be convinced i think
thank you
uh thank you again scarlett council
byford
thank you chair
um i'm ver i disagree uh i think that
the street scene is so varied
i cannot honestly see how
it this
this alteration would um upset the
the general streets in how it would be
out of keeping
um i can see that there
there is some harm to the neighbours but
i have to say
i think it's minimal and i think lengths
have been taken to
to lessen the harm
nobody likes change but i think overall
it's a world it's a good design
and i feel that i i would like to
support this application thank you uh
thank you councilman
uh council pew
thank you chair yeah i mean i i disagree
with councillor garner's comments uh not
because i don't like council ghana i
think he's great but um i think that the
street scene has changed uh enough uh
well it's changed already uh to warrant
further change um if this was the first
of the entire row of that then i'd i'd
be more concerned but i think it's it's
already the street scene is already
evolving um and i think it's hard to
justify any of the properties going
above one the ground floor when others
already have
my only question um to the planning
officer would be that
in relation to the variance in height
between 21 and
23
the nearby neighbours
and the variant of elevation
does that impact on the ground floor
windows on that side
not being frosted
as in i suppose the question i'm asking
is that does the fence line cover that
for sufficient privacy or is that an
issue because of
the raised elevation of of property
number 21
can you
wherever this comes up sorry i'm just
trying to find the right elevation so
the this i think these two are existing
windows just flicking back to
the existing floor plan so
um
so that's the existing floor plan with a
ground floor level so there's one large
window already serving the bathroom so
it is likely to be an obscure glazed
window facing the neighbor
and then the proposal is for um the
shower room window um
what appears to be a utility room
and
then i think that looks like it's the
existing window that's probably been
broken down into two separate windows
because it's a similar width and then
this appears to be the new window going
in which is serving the cinema room
so that window
is this window here
now looking
i mean this is this
this bit here is the new um wall that's
going in
up to the boundary
but
looking back at that
photo i'm not quite clear on what the
actual boundary
treatment is it looks like it's quite
low actually my uh
apology so my question is then is that
all seems fine the the
so the kind of flaw to ceiling window at
the back that's being proposed will that
impact on privacy particularly in the
rear elevation yes sorry sorry no no on
the side renovation the kind of
extension at the back there's a floor to
ceiling window it looks like if you go
to the
the side bit of those four windows
this is what that one there will that
impact because of the change in
elevation will that impact on privacy to
do with the fence line
um i don't know what the boundary
treatment is
for that rear garden if if
if i may um so the rear
um
the rear window if you go to the
it's the
yeah sorry you've got the wrong one yeah
there we go um so the floor to ceiling
one is is at the rear so that's actually
um directly adjacent to
um what's effectively a garage on the
neighbouring property that's the other
side and it's obviously it's it's to the
rear where obviously there is that the
boundary fence as emma's just said the
existing boundary fence
um actually means that the windows that
are in the property at the moment
towards the front on the side of the
motion
are actually visible you know you can
see them over the fence because the
fence isn't actually that high but
because of where this this window is to
the rear um with the relationship with
the existing um
garage that's there it's not considered
they would be overlooking and also this
the added element i suppose is that you
know you you could add
ground floor side windows into the
existing building but obviously you're
correct to identify this because this is
the expanded section of of the extension
but no it's not considered that they
would be overlooking uh because of the
level difference in this instance from
the rear
thank you
you cannot quite have with that council
pew that no that answers my question
thank you thank you
yes
sorry i wasn't sure where you were
looking like my ears didn't hear my name
properly i got your name right that time
you did yes and you weren't even looking
at it um
i have some real mixed feelings and
really undecided at this moment um and
i'm partly with uh councillor ghana on
this um if i only look to the left of
the property
i think this is a fantastic beautiful
design uh i really like that the look of
it
um but i can see a domino effect working
downhill that is like one gets converted
in from a bungalow to a house and then
the next one and the next one
and the impact of that is around the
question about sunlight and the
direction of the sun
which
is that is major part of the loss
because the the concern is coming from
number 23
which is then going to be overshadowed
and so i was wondering if we could look
again back at the direction of sunlight
and and the the degree of impact of the
loss of that natural light
on the bungalow and and warmth from the
sun in the summer
uh if i may
just come in
we mustn't preempt what might happen in
the future
i don't understand what you're saying
about once something happens it uh
but if you don't mind me saying that to
you yeah apologies it
was just what it appears to have
happened so far totally understand but
uh
emma can you
so this is the block plan again so you
can see this is this is showing um
it's north obviously in this direction
here so this first floor extension will
be having some potential impact on this
side elevation of number 23
it's difficult to know exactly how much
that impact will what that impact will
be but six and a half meters is quite a
good distance between the properties
and the increase in height because of
the use level of the property being kept
quite low
um it's an increase of two meters if it
was a full extra floor and roof being
added on an extra floor is usually
around 2.4 meters and then if you had a
roof on top it could be higher so if it
was a full two-story building with a
pitch roof on top it would be a lot
taller so they have attempted to keep it
as low as possible with the eaves now
only going up the 2.2 meters i think
directly opposite because there's a
change in level from front to back as
well
as well as between the plots um there's
a difference depending on where you you
are with the property so at the opposite
the window of the neighboring property
that's got to concern it's 2.1 meters
the increase so it's slightly less
directly opposite that window
so it's just our view that with that
distance and the fact is the side facing
windows and you know primary
main windows are usually in the front
and rear elevations it's appreciated
this is a a window serve in a bedroom
and it is the only window serving that
bedroom
but at the same time it's it is
side-facing it does have limited outlook
and light anyway just because the fact
it is facing onto a side boundary and
facing towards another property anyway
so it's just a matter of judgment as to
whether this increase in height is going
to have a significant harmful impact
upon the light to that window and with
this distance and with the height
increase it's not considered that the
impact would be significant
thank you ever we should come back yeah
sorry i was thinking uh
you haven't really answered my question
about the direction of the sun the north
south east west direction could i could
we just it was mentioned earlier but
could we just
go back to that
well the the the sun is coming up um in
this direction here over to the east
it's coming up along the south here so
middle of the day would be down here so
at that point so in the mornings there
there will be limited impact on light
from the sun coming up and then as it's
coming around
at this point here
that's when that would be blocking some
light through to the window because the
window's over here so this being first
floor level at the point of the sun
reaching this point that's when there
will be some loss of light
and that will carry on around the
afternoon
presumably up to the point of um early
evening when there may be some some
potential back there although it's
probably going to be blocked by the
existing properties or the neighboring
properties garage at that point so
the the main light will still be just in
the morning and there will be some
impact probably throughout the day from
that increased height
is that is that answering it
thank you
um mr thorne i'm sorry i can't let you
come back in i'm sorry
uh counselor right
thank you chairman um i've i've also got
mixed mixed views but uh for me it's um
looking at the other properties that the
other two story properties um the
materials that are being used are quite
different and i'm wondering if um
something could be done alternatively to
timber
just to soften the the over the overall
look
the existing properties haven't got
timber they're they're kind of um
they're affected the walls are faced um
i'm just wondering if if we could if
they could not have the timber timber
panels
and something softer
that's all right
yeah well
i think the thing is what this what
these photos aren't showing is is the
overall context of where this is so
this is a road that you can see from
dancer park drive and in dunstan park
drive if you you know if you drive along
there you can see
a huge mix of materials heights designs
you don't tend to get two properties
that look the same along that road and
this will be seen within the context of
dante park drive and it's a shame
probably that we haven't got any photos
showing the other side of dunn's part
drive because then you probably would
see a lot more timber cladding because
there is a lot along that road so i
think whilst you're looking at the
photos that we put before you which are
showing in relation to these three
properties to the side which are mainly
rendered with some brickwork i think in
the overall context of of the area it's
not actually going to appear out of
keeping given the range of materials
uh thank you emma
i don't see any other
members wishing to
counsel pat moore
thank you chair
i live nearby
and
how i live is
i wouldn't live in the house without any
sun shining on it when it's sunny but
a case like this
it's only going to lose
i think
maybe two hours a day
or three at the very most because
the sun comes up
down here
and it works its way around so it's
going to be before that house
covers
or stops the uh
bungalow
getting light
it's going to be
uh
say two three o'clock in the afternoon
and then by four o'clock
the sun is over that side and it's
working its way around the back
so they could
apart from that
if
the people at number
21
uh they could always plant 20 foot
conifers in their back garden like i've
had to deal with
and it that is a nuisance
but it can be done
i think thank you uh councilman moore
well illustrated thank you those thank
you
any other members wish to speak
councillor zesky
joe looking at the design and everything
and having driven past that area
probably thousands of times
i don't see an issue with the design
because there is a very big
mix of properties going down dumpton
along that area so i don't see a problem
with the design
again they've kept the the height down
quite well um
it's it's not a major issue i think i'll
be supporting it thank you
thank you
council okay members i can't see any
other
who wish to speak so i'm going to put
the
officer's recommendation to you which is
for approval
of those who
agree please show their hands
against
abstentions
that is carried
thank you members thank you for that
right once again moving on that
concludes uh public speaking at this
meeting i will call upon james now to
read out the remaining planning
applications if a member has always
wishes to reserve an application
may they please
shout at me
thank you james thank you chair so the
uh remaining two items then um first one
5b for approval which is 9 holly road
ramsgate
and 5c defer and delegate to offices
which is beach lodge old boundary road
west gate on the sea
okay
it's christmas
bear with me a moment please
members if i could have a proposal
uh for the one which isn't going to be
discussed
that's 5b
council pew um
thank you seconded by council bayford if
members agree
thank you
right i'm passing over to emma for
the item bridge uh beach lodge or
boundary road in westgate
thank you chairman um this is the
site here so this is beach lodge you can
see to the south is the old boat house
the neighboring property is quite a
distance from beach house beach lodge um
and then here is one to three sandy
villas which are three
new build um houses on the corner here
um located to the rear of the former um
not pub
this is uh the the beach lodge in this
location here so this is an old um
google image so you can see this was the
car park area um associated with the
knot but this is now the location of
three houses um that have been
constructed here
and then this is just from above so you
can see beach lodge in this location
here and again you can see this is uh
the neighboring property and there's
quite a distance in this location and so
the site lies within the conservation
area the property is not listed
um but the consideration has been given
to um the heritage um assets of the
property and it's considered it it may
be classed as a non-designated heritage
asset
so this is the building this is beach
lodge
so it's an existing um
four bed dwelling although it's not
clear if it's really full but it's four
bed at first floor level and then
there's other bedrooms or rooms at
ground floor level which potentially
could also be used as bedrooms and then
there's also some space at basement
level as well
this is um to the left of the property
so you can see existing side access to
the rear of the property and then this
is the garden here of the old boat house
and this again is the old boathouse on
the left looking towards the application
property on the right
and again
looking towards the application property
which is this one here so in terms of
the front elevation there's very few
alterations to the front elevation or
the side elevation most of the works are
at the rear
then this is to the right hand side and
you can see now the
newly built dwelling to the right of the
property
and this is now from the rear looking
towards the existing rear elevation and
again you can see this on the left hand
side one of the three new dwellings that
have been constructed
and again further out you can see again
those those dwellings and then this is a
car park area which is used um by the
residential units here and the
residential units within the former not
pub
um sorry it's not very clear but this is
the site plan showing the um the plot
and then the extensions at the rear
and also this is also not a very clear
plan but basically what is happening is
it's a four bed dwelling and they are
subdividing it to create two two bed
dwellings
so there will be a dividing boundary
wall created through the middle of the
of the rear garden so these would be
individual gardens linked to the
property there would be a side access
that would allow for
refuge to be brought out to the front of
the property and cycle access
and there's cycle storage within the
rear garden
and then this is showing the existing
front elevation
and this is a proposed front elevation
so
very few changes i believe it's just
some changes within the
front door area and in terms of the
light wells one of these is being
expanded at basement level just to
create more light into the basement
and then this is the existing side
elevation facing the old boathouse
and that's a repose so again you can see
no changes within the side elevation
and this is the rear elevation so this
is the main change
so this is the extension that's taking
place so it's a three-story extension
tying in with the existing rear
projection of the building so you can
see this is existing dormer they're
looking to erect two additional dormers
of the same design and size to the rear
elevation
the this is an amended plan so the
original plan did show two large flat
roof dormers within this roof space
and it also showed a new window going in
in this location here which was
i believe casement window so out of
keeping with the
sliding sash design that you can see um
at existing first and second floor level
so it's been amended to remove the
dormers following concerns that were
raised and also to change this window
design back into a sliding sash design
in keeping with the other windows
at ground floor level you can see that
french doors with floor to ceiling
glazing are going in
and then this is the other side
elevation and again no changes actually
within the elevation but this is then
that rear
extension so you can see it's going down
to basement level um i believe there's
some excavation work going on at
basement level in order to create some
access into the basement
and then this is just showing the floor
plan so this is the existing basement
floor plan so you can see there's
currently three rooms there
showing that there's potentially some
access at this point here um
and then they're looking to excavate
this area so that they can come out from
this lounge area through the french
doors up the stairs to the raised garden
area
so this is the subdivision you can see
the wall running through the middle so
you've got lounge
in each property at basement level you
can see the um light well at the front
here that's been expanded so it's the
same as the light well on the right hand
side
and then this is the existing uh first
sort of ground floor existing ground
floor with the lounge and it shows just
two rooms on the left hand side here
and this is the proposed so this is the
large kitchen area
and this is the bathroom at the front
so again the same for for both
properties
and then first floor level is currently
showing us four bedrooms with a bathroom
and then they're just looking to infill
this corner area in order to create two
spacious bedrooms at first floor level
with ensuites
and then nothing is taking place at roof
level now so previously the the plan did
show a third bedroom in each of the
properties at roof level but that has
now been removed
and again this is now just showing the
roof plan so you can see the two
additional dormers and the extension
so the main issues are the impact on the
conservation area
um the conservation officer has raised a
few concerns previously was
raising concerns with the dormer windows
which have now been removed and the
window
but even after the plans haven't been
amended there is still some concern from
the conservation officer with the
ground floor um french doors and the
modernising of the appearance of the
building which she considers to have
quite a
a heritage appearance and and
potentially is a non-designated heritage
asset so
concerns are raised to do with that but
in terms of uh the case officer's view
in terms of the conservation area that
they would be at ground floor level and
you actually in terms of the views
towards the building you wouldn't
actually
really get a true feeling of those
additional doors going in because of the
boundary wall that runs around the site
so it would have very limited impact on
on the conservation area from that
addition
in terms of the um the extension
as long as the bricks are are in keeping
with the existing bricks then it's not
so there's really going to be
significant harm this extension is set
back behind this
rear elevation so it's actually not
projected any any further than the this
rear elevation the dormers will tie in
with the existing dormer and the window
proportions will be similar so
it will be in character with the
existing property
and it's not considered there will be
real significant harm to the the
conservation area
and concern has been raised with the
fact there's no parking on the site um
but given the fact it's a at least a
four bed unit at the moment going to two
two beds then it's not there's not
considered to be any significant
increase in vehicle movements as a
result of the fact that the bedrooms are
not increasing
and in terms of the neighbouring impact
the additional windows that would be
within this extension and within the
dormers would be looking towards the
parking area and the rear gardens of the
properties themselves and would not
result in any significant overlooking um
to enabling properties and this
extension itself as i said it's set back
behind this rear elevation and therefore
is not going to be having any light or
outlook input
impact
so overall is is recommended
for um defer and delegates subject to
the legal agreement for the spa
contribution
um with um yeah the impact on the
conservation era by officers being
considered acceptable thank you
uh thank you emma i move the officer's
recommendation is adopted because the
vice chair please second
second nature thank you council
ghana thank you yeah thanks sarah there
were
three main reasons why i thought it was
important that we
actually
discussed this application
um
having read the report and read a number
of the
objections from
the neighbors and other locals and from
westgate town council
the first of these relates to
the fact that this is a non-designated
heritage heritage asset
and the conservation
officer
was actually quite
fearment in her
objection to the application proposed
i think
not necessarily because of the impact on
the conservation area
but as much to do with the fact that
this
important asset
is being altered
i did read a little bit into it um
and apparently this there was someone a
famous local resident from the 19th
century had this built john
grieveson who was one of the first
builders and inhabitants
of westgate so i'm actually quite
surprised that it isn't a listed
building um but obviously that's not
down to us or me but
so that that was one of the concerns i
thought we ought to consider
the other concern i have which is raised
by a number of people
relates to
the
biodiversity in the back garden the
trees
and hedges which haven't been mentioned
um i know on the plans
that because it has been split into two
units there are two gardens being
created at the back
um
i can't i can see there's obviously
going to be alterations there's
obviously going to be some removal of
that some of those trees and hedges and
there isn't any
tree report or anything like that and
there isn't a landscaping plan so i
would have liked to have seen
consideration given that we could at
least get some conditions on here that
um
made that develop the developer
at least
replant significant number of trees and
hedges if some are removed
and the third
issue
which has been mentioned
is about the um
car parking and you know i accept it's
moving from it's still going to have the
same amount of bedrooms
but this is two separate units now so
there are more likely to be more car
owners living in this unit
much as i'd like to see car ownership
dwindle over the years and there are
likely to be more car owners because
there's
more likely to be
more adults who own cars in either unit
and so those are my concerns and i
obviously would be interested to hear
what other
members might have to say to alleviate
some of my concerns
thank you thank you council ghana
council robin
yeah thank you chair i like it
i have to say um
you know i think the
design is great
we're going from one to one into two
and you know it's not listed building
obviously it's
situated within the conservation area it
doesn't matter who's lived there be
before we're dealing with this now
and not only that i think in any
heritage
uh buildings that we have they've all
been altered changed all over the years
and you know we've had large buildings
put into flats etc etc etc so um
yeah i don't see that as an issue is
relation to the tree in a conservation
area it is
protected under law so unless they make
an application to remove the tree the
tree will remain and be
protected and uh
i i don't know whether they are whether
there are hedges there but even if there
are
uh as it stands at the moment uh the
hedges are not protected in in in law in
for here within that conservation area
and it could be scrubbed out grabbed out
what whatever i just think um
i think the parking issue is a bit of a
mismatch is is a bit of a nothing to be
quite honest
um we all suffer from parking we all
suffer you know and uh
you know
maybe then you know where's where's the
electric parking
charges gonna gonna go when we all get
electric cars and whatever but
overall
i think the design is good i think the
the going from one to one into two
i have no objection to it chair i just
think it's a good development so i'll be
supporting the development thank you
chair
uh thank you very much council for all
and council bayford
thank you chair um
i share councillor gardner's concern
that there's no tree report
would could
is this just because
the tree can't be changed in a
conservation area i don't know um and
and there's no landscaping however
um i think it's a very very clever
design
i think you know to to make two
well-designed properties and with
very little change at the front
so as not to affect the conservation
area i i i think it is very very clever
design and
yes it's a pity that there isn't no um
tree report i'd be interested to know
um what what is going to happen to to
the tree that's there at the moment but
in every other respect i i would support
this application
thank you councilmanford i'm not sure
whether emma has
taken that on
thank you chair um so the
the the image that you can see
shows you can see there's a tree um
that that's obviously lost its leaves in
in the winter which is pretty much on
the boundary between this site and
um the the new dwellings
um
that is primarily the main tree on this
site um if have you got the is there any
real image
so we're just going to see if there's an
aerial image um which this sometimes
would usually put in
um
oh there we go actually there we go ah
it's a little bit low res so it doesn't
quite work um if you carry on going
forward apologies members bear with us
keep going forward
just the view of the side
uh the left hand side of the beach
launches okay there we go yes so you can
see um in this image um a number of a
number of trees which are on the
boundary with old boundary road and the
tree um and so there there aren't any
trees that are in the middle of the
properties um
sorry the beach lodge properties uh
garden that's proposed to be removed
obviously in terms of the considerations
when it's a tree in a conservation area
is whether or not we would tpo those
trees um we do hear what what's been
said with regards to concerns about well
what what's that rear garden gonna look
like because i think on the site plan it
does show simply a sort of a lawned area
rather than anything else and i think
from from discussions that that we've
we've just had with regards to this um
if members were particularly concerned
about the need for planting on this site
in the rear garden because there's going
to be a new boundary treatment in the
middle so there is a change at the back
there
that a condition could be added that
prior to occupation
there would be some information provided
about soft landscaping the rear which
would allow officers to look at you know
what could be retained because obviously
the trees are actually on the boundary
in this site so they don't necessarily
need to go
um they're not of substantial size
that i think would necessarily warrant a
tpo but it will allow us to consider
what's being proposed in terms of
landscaping at the rear um and and i
think we officers would be happy to add
that condition on
if
excuse me and if um the chair would
would
also be minded to do that and get
agreement from the vice chair then we
could add that onto the motion if that
was considered appropriate
well i've been told to do something
overnight
so
yes i do propose that and i'm sure
makes sense councillor coleman cook was
second i will second that yeah thank you
do you all agree
great thank you uh
councillor i will bring back but i've
got councillor pube council ghana first
yeah yeah i'm sure i'm sure that would
be a agreed and appreciate that and i
just i understand it might not be a very
substantial tree
and
in
one view not one a tpo but maybe placing
a tpo on it would enable it to become
a substantial tree that's um some stage
in the future so but the your proposed
changes around the landscaping plan
do um
are very good and helpful so thank you
very much i would just like to come back
just on something that counselor auburn
said about um
conservation and conservation areas
and i understand what what he's saying
i'm about some buildings being changed
whether they're heritage assets or
listed buildings or whatever i i was i'm
always keen to pay heed to what our
our officers say in their reports and
the conservation officer
in her report
was quite
quite vehement in her
her
view
that she very much objects to the
application proposed and suggested that
is appropriately reconsidered so this is
that was why i wanted to make sure
her
feelings were heard at the meeting we
might not agree with her
um and we might
think otherwise but i just wanted to
make sure that was understood by
everybody thank god very much i did spot
that myself that is
yourself as a council pew
thank you chair yeah i mean i was going
to raise concerns about
the vegetation and trees at the back but
that's already been addressed so that's
brilliant um
i quite like it i think it looks quite
good i think that it's a good idea to
divide up a
a building um
we always have a shortage of smaller
residences particularly in westgate and
around the coast and i think this is a
good idea i do have a slight concern
about parking particularly at the front
um from my recollection old boundary
road is never really particularly busy
um but only in the summer but then i
think that's part and parcel we're doing
so close to a nice beach um
i do wonder that although it is in a
conservation area
does that mean that less weight is added
to that
particularly as the externally the
facade at the front isn't changing um
particularly in relation to the new
builds
to the right of the property does that
then impact on the wider conservation
area and i only asked that because there
there's such a contrast between this
property and
the adjacent ones
whether you whether residents or anyone
agrees with them or not but it
considering the rest of that road
they do look quite out and keeping so
will this change even just dividing up
this property
uh exacerbate that and make that worse
or is it viewed that it won't i'm just
like a bit of clarity on that
thank you how's pure taking point there
emma
um i i don't think there's a real
concern from our point of view regarding
the subdivision the impact on on the
conservation of from from that point of
view
um
i think as you've mentioned i think the
front elevation is is probably the most
important aspect of this building and
this is not changing i think there's one
potentially a change to the front door
maybe um but other than that all of the
windows remain the same there's no
changes at all to any of the brickwork
and the only other change was that the
light well on the left-hand side was
being
slightly deepened
um so in terms of the conservation area
i think the main
views of this building because obviously
it's obviously an open space and we've
got tennis courts opposite so the main
um
sort of significance of this building is
the front elevation really and the views
you get of it across the open space so i
think whilst the conservation officer
has raised concerns and in terms of this
building being a non-designated heritage
asset
it's difficult it's not it still doesn't
have listed status and therefore we
can't be considering just the impact the
harm to just the building itself we
still have to be considering what visual
impact that that alteration is having on
the area so whilst
it the building itself we think has
maybe more merit than other buildings
potentially within the conservation area
we still have to argue that there's harm
in order for us to refuse the
application and i think the concern with
the extension is that is quite a minor
extension really in fit in something a
corner of a building
um not coming out any further than the
existing renovation and we have quite
sympathetic dormer design that's in
keeping with the existing ordnance on
the property so
i think it's just it's
it's difficult for us to really make the
argument that the infill of this this
very small extension whilst it is a
ground first of all level you will have
views of that across the car park i
think like you mentioned the fact that
we do have three modern houses right
next to it
it makes it difficult for an argument
that this small extension is going to be
resulting in significant harm when
you've got these buildings next door
that are very different in appearance
so i think that's yeah that's helped you
uh thank you for that emma council curry
chair um can i just say i think the
change is at the rear of the property
and the three the two added dormers
actually improve the look of the
building
and uh i think it looks very impressive
um at the rear of the building now thank
you thank you council curry i can't see
any other speakers so
i'll put this to your members
it is for defer and delegate
those in favor
against
the
is there isn't that is carried
thank you members
uh that concludes the meeting tonight
but before you'll fly away i think it's
my duty to say thank you for this year i
think so i know i should
um
interesting year been on telly for a few
months and obviously being back in here
for a few months
but can i wish all your families
officers as well
a very happy christmas and plea please
stay with all what's going on in this
crazy world
stay safe
yes you can
no doubt the whole wide world's heard
that as well so thank you members and
all the best to you thank you
you